luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin if
you're just getting into crypto it's the perfect
place to start guys anna welcome back to another
episode of the leia heil pun show we have done
so many episodes now i think we've done around
this could be the 65th episode so that's 65 weeks
over a year i'm pretty pleased with how
it's going um so it's actually powered by
um icon plus capital the vc firm
so check them out i'm on socials
and it is sponsored by block fi so i actually
use block fi to earn i think right now they have
one of the most competitive interest rates it's
around nine percent on some of your stable coins
um so i'm going to leave a link in the description
for you leave it in the comment section so if you
do want to sign up i think right now you can also
get around 250 when you sign up and get amazing
competitive interest rates i use them super happy
with the experience so i'd really recommend them
okay so today um i have a friend joining me on
the show um so i'm super excited um it is let's
see if you can guess okay so she's an influencer
she is a speaker educator and a content creator
it is miss teen crypto what's up hey thank you for
having me so excited to be here yeah it's great to
have you so for those that don't know we actually
met we had the pleasure of finally meeting um in
miami um a few weeks ago so why don't you tell
us why you were down in miami i was actually down
in miami for miami crypto experience that was
really fun met a ton of really cool people i'm
happy we got to go out we ate some like really
nice pasta it was really cool yeah yeah yeah
it was good it was good i actually took um yeah
we went to one of my favorite places in miami um
and miami's just becoming such a great crypto hub
it's unbelievable so yeah it was really good to
meet you and it's amazing that at such a young age
you're not even 20 yet you're still a teenager i
miss teen crypto you're having all these different
speaking opportunities which is so exciting so
i want to go back a little bit and understand
how you actually you know decided to get into
crypto yeah so my dad has actually been in the
space for the past five years into crypto and he
used to talk about it all the time i didn't listen
because all i heard were like numbers finance just
things i didn't understand i didn't think i could
essentially do anything with it like i couldn't do
anything with stocks that's how i related it but
when i was around 16 he showed me a transaction
and all you had to do was scan a qr code copy
and paste an address and that's literally it
you transact you're done so i just saw that like
you know that was gonna change the way we transact
i saw none of my friends none of my family knew
what bitcoin was never mind how easy it is to use
so then i just you know joined twitter a year
and a half later and yeah that's pretty much it
that's crazy you're so lucky to have a dad that's
been able to just to teach you all these things um
especially at such a young age it's so amazing but
that's interesting because you mentioned stocks
so i'm assuming stocks is just overwhelming right
like you you couldn't even go near that well at
13 no like i i just didn't pay attention i just
didn't think i could do anything with it like nfts
bitcoin and all this cryptocurrency like that
stuff that you could do things with at any age
so that was what also pulled me in as well
like anyone with an internet connection
can download a wallet and start spending and
transacting i know that you did a tweet the other
day and you were like bitcoin if you love freedom
you love bitcoin so i'm really interested to know
what you know other than like use case and it all
being very fun and zesty as you put it but like
what actually what actually about crypto um really
drives you because i know that you're you're
spending a lot of your time especially you know on
the weekends going down to times square and like
making all these different videos it takes a
lot of energy a lot of passion and interest to
actually go out and create content on something
um so for you what is the driving force
it's essentially being in control of your value
in control of your funds um one thing i learned
from a friend of mine clint westwood is that your
ti your money essentially is an accumulation of
your time your energy and the amount like you
can't spend like you used to um i like you know
a burger used to be like 20 cents at mcdonald's
and now you're lucky if it's on the dollar menu
so you can't you don't have the person you used
to get a dollar wait you used to get a dollar
you just get a burger for 20 cents a mcdonald's
something like that i i was looking at a menu like
an old picture and it was something around that
i don't quote me on it because there's definitely
something around that um like i know you used to
get like two slices and a coke for like 50 cents
um in new york and now it's like a dollar or more
it's it's crazy it's literally nuts so the fact
that we could you know control our value control
our assets with bitcoin and cryptocurrency and
actually have that like peer-to-peer it reminds
me of like you know being in the cafeteria when
i was little trading like those pokemon and
yu-gi-oh cards just with your friends so that
it reminded me of that and in school did you ever
have any kind of formal financial education at all
no not at all and that surprised me a lot because
you know getting into like the real world kind of
you know i had a job for a little while and i
just didn't like even know what a check was you
know i didn't know like how to catch that how do
you start getting a bank account all that stuff i
don't know um i don't know how to pay taxes um it
was nothing that was taught in school and yeah the
most that i ever saw what was an investment class
that i could have taken as a senior in high school
where you just followed one stock for each uh
quarter of the year so there's four quarters you
would follow four stocks and that's it and it's
whoever made the most money would do good in the
class and i just didn't see that i got something
that would help me so i just didn't take it
that's so crazy i mean i think that's how wait
how old were you when you offered that um it
was literally last year so 17-18 that's pretty
interesting though because we're not really even
we weren't even offered something like that um oh
maybe we were we could choose to take an economic
class at that age but actually it's more like 16
to 17 you can you can take economics but you just
you know you don't choose it because like you
tend to you choose subjects that you've already
studied so that you could then get a better grade
and go on and on but um but yeah i think that's
such a shame that you know we're not taught
financial literacy in school and and i have
a whole theory as to why that is um we don't need
to get into that if you if you have any theories
you're welcome to tell me but um how do you how
do your friends then deal with all of this right
so you're obviously talking to them about bitcoin
talking to him about litecoin um can they relate
to you or do they think that you're absolutely
nuts well at the beginning i was absolutely not
um right you know walking around school and
being the one that talked about like this
internet stuff like you know people didn't think
i was i people thought i was out there to say the
least but now a lot of people are actually coming
back around and sending me dm's like oh you know
i'm on open c i have 500 in eath what do i do with
it or i have 500 i want to sign up for coinbase
how what should i buy things like that so you
know people are starting to get into it they're
questioning it more than they used to at first it
was just kind of something that they rubbed off
and it was just like whatever but now it's
catching a lot of traction a lot of mainstream
media attention a lot of big events happening
especially you know my friends being in new york
they're seeing things like nft nyc 6 000 plus
people so the curiosity is definitely sparking
yeah i think it's fascinating and i think what
kind of is is an interesting way to look at it
as well as is your is the older generation right
so at school your friends are sort of getting
it now but what do your teachers think because i
remember you saying that you actually did a class
or something like you you sort of run a class
about it how did that go i can't believe they
even let you do that i know so you know it was
really a kind of a mixed reaction in my high
school which was so funny i had teachers coming
up to me telling me i shouldn't be doing what i'm
doing bitcoin's a party yeah they said i shouldn't
be involved in this bitcoin's a ponzi scheme
um recently i had a teacher tell me they're still
worried about the game i'm in which is crypto um
but wait wait wait wait pause on that put the
teacher said what they called it a game like yeah
they said they were worried about the game and i
was like oh okay that's fine don't worry um i i
literally just said it's okay like it's fine um so
i just you know kept on with the conversation and
said goodbye but he it's a nice teacher they just
don't understand yet but there are other teachers
that do so this was uh one of my teachers
in school he's younger he's around like 27
28 i would guess or his 30s young 30s but he was
just like curious because one of my friends asked
me in class and was like yo randy like what's
going on with elon musk and bitcoin because that
was when i first started tweeting about it and
i was just like oh bitcoin is just peer-to-peer
digital currency it's literally online cash
and my teacher started asking me questions and
it turned into like this whole crypto q a and it
actually happened like in that class and you know
other teachers have asked me and others and
it just turned into a q a but only a few
that's really amazing i love that um i can imagine
i can imagine doing that in school i just i just
couldn't i think when i got up in school i was
probably just like ranting about i don't know
like politics or something like that as i tend to
do as i tend to do now you know um but you have
like a huge interest in nfts and i do see value
in nfcs but i'm not as big on it as you are so
sort of just tell me more like why why do you why
are you interested in nfts i think everything's
going to be an nft or at least close to everything
um you know we're scratching the surface of what
nfcs can be right now which are simple art um
music even that's getting taken up a few notches
right so instead of a musician just putting
out their song as an nft they're now creating
albums and something that justin blau did uh he's
a very famous music producer making nfcs on nifty
gateway one of his genesis nfts what he did was
if you bought that nft you got a physical item
which was a sound wave and then you had access to
vip you know section of his concerts for life so
those are like different utilities you can offer
also you can think of it as proof of authenticity
like my high school diploma that should have been
an nft you could directly see when it was created
and where the nft has gone you can make sure
it's not transferable or non-burnable so that
way it has to stay on the blockchain and you can
see where it came from like new york high school
sent this image at this time to miss teen nfts and
it's just a lot of things like that like the d to
your house can be an nft potentially one day i
do agree with you um i certainly think that um
i do think that like everything is going
digital um so it sort of makes sense for
for physical items in the real world to have
that digital authentication um i always say
the same example for example like a rolex watch i
understand that that can actually the same rolex
watch can actually be a different price depending
on the supply chain where it was you know where it
came from whether it came from like the uae versus
the west i know that can fluctuate in the price
and so having that history put on the blockchain
totally agree with you um but do you do you kind
of see it as like any particular any particular
blockchain would do better i know that people
are now starting to experiment well kind of it's
very early but they want to put nfts on bitcoin
um then you have like the issues with gas fees on
ethereum then there's solana which is obviously
much um much cheaper so do you have a preference
over which blockchains that you use well i don't
really have a preference i've been minting on wax
for a long time now since like november last year
i don't know wax wait tell me about wax because
i remember you mentioned it the other day yeah
so wax is actually doing partnering with amc so
if you bought if you were like an amc stub member
like one of their vip members you were able to
buy an early access ticket to the new spider-man
movie and receive nfts so that's that's something
that's really awesome um new ways to like there's
going to be like amc loyalty programs so that
way if you're a shareholder i saw william quigley
on uh cnbc this morning so if you're a amc
shareholder you get an nft that gives you like
more perks at the movie theater like discounts
advanced ticket sales things like that um
so i preferably use wax just because it's feasible
for gen z um like buying a one dollar nft on
ethereum could be pretty hard because of the gas
fees um never there's a lot of great projects on
ethereum but the things i can do on wax are just
a lot more like i could do air drops like if you
want my new uh nft drop that ends today so if you
buy both nfts just for having them in your wallet
i'll give you a free one um that's something i
couldn't do if i was using ethereum for example
just be too expensive that makes sense that's
really interesting and how do your i'm always
like going back to this but like how does how do
your friends gen z kind of take to this especially
in comparison to the older generation because
sometimes people often look at i don't really
agree with this but there's this idea that bitcoin
is the boomer coin right so it's the coin which
made everybody who's like 30 plus it made them
super rich and now you have this new generation
that want to get into crypto want to make money um
and there's like a generation divide within crypto
right so what do your friends and your generation
tend to sort of gravitate towards more i mean it's
kind of equal um you find out about bitcoin and
then you question like okay this is digital money
how does that work then nfts like what does this
mean um what what is an nft how how does it play a
role in crypto essentially uh but i think a lot
of my friends take to nfts because you know we
understand the concept of digital property like if
you didn't take a selfie you weren't there so like
we understand the whole concept of i took this
selfie i was at this place at this time here's the
metadata on my picture from my phone and all that
stuff so like having that authentication as an nft
you know it just goes in so seamlessly with our
lives i don't think bitcoin is like you know a
boomer coin or whatever i think we're so new
like bitcoin's a tween she's only 12. like you
know what i mean it's so nude like this is still
new money um you know all of these exchanges are
new everything happening is so new and i think
bitcoin will always have that standard of like
being the store of value that digital gold um
and things like that and nfts are going to play
a role in like decentralizing like assets like
deeds to our houses and diplomas things like that
i think what's interesting about you is that
you've taken a really different route because
when we met you were saying how you may not
go to university is that still the case as
of right now yeah yeah so i find that fascinating
because um particularly in america especially in
comparison to england there's more of a focus on
the importance of university and if you don't go
then it's all going to come crashing down and
you're going to be homeless and it's terrible
um i obviously don't agree with that and i fully
support the idea that you don't want to go to
university so i'd love to understand more about
why you don't want to go and what you would do
instead honestly um crypto was just a passion
of mine and it's something that makes me really
happy and i feel like it's it's something i could
pursue forever um crypto we're so new here that
you know we could all make a difference and we
could all do something really good for the world
um you know going to college that's something
that i guess is always going to be an option
but for me right now to have this opportunity to
be a part of crypto and be in this community i
just don't think that this this is a one-time
once in a lifetime opportunity and i'm gonna
take it like my community they've supported me
to the point where like it just it fuels my fire
and i i always want to do this yeah i think
that's amazing um i don't necessarily regret
going to university because it was good for the
time and everything um but if i would do it again
if i was if i was in your position i certainly
wouldn't go especially with everything that you've
built right now um so i think yeah i i think it's
going to be great honestly i'm so excited for you
so thank you something which i do find i am
curious about then because of course like
you know friends can understand nfts and they
can understand crypto but like in terms of you
like do you find it difficult because you know
you you're not doing something normal right like
you and i understand everybody watching we're all
sort of on the same wavelength we also understand
but like it's actually not normal like i know we
have mass adoption but it's not normal especially
saying that you don't want to go to
university um you'd rather pursue crypto
like how do you find that on like a personal
level sort of navigating through everything
it's it's difficult i'm not gonna lie um you know
being into crypto is already something that's so
like odd just because like i'm we're so deep into
it like once you get into crypto you fall down
this rabbit hole and everything you look at is
just not the same like this could be an nft or i
should be paying for crypto here and you know just
relating everything to it it's just something that
no one else i know really does and you know they
might like crypto but they're not as involved and
um i honestly think the train of thought is
different but like we all still get along we're
all still hanging out but it's it's hard it's not
as like you know easy as it used to be because
i'm just again like a lot of the friends i know
they're all in college they're all like you know
going out on the weekends and you know doing like
focusing on finals and all this stuff and i'm just
here like you know streaming and having a lot of
fun and like innovating and crypto so it's like so
different i'm so excited for you i just think that
like yeah forget the finals come down to miami
start building start making money start you know
creating something for yourself don't have any
student debt it's just going to be really really
great honestly um but i really actually want to
get your thoughts on the metaverse because i know
you're like like you said you're big on like when
you're big on nfts um but do you have any thoughts
on the metaverse are you excited for it at all i
mean the metaphors i'm not really sure right now
like my complete thoughts on it it's this is all
like real like new emerging technology i think the
metaverse is gonna play a role in like a lot of
you know social events um you know like i think
paris hilton if i'm not mistaken did a performance
in the metaverse and a lot of people were able to
attend whereas like if that was a real life event
a lot of people couldn't attend um so i think
it's definitely gonna play a role in social
events um probably gonna help bring adoption of
cryptocurrency because again it's a digital world
um i'm not too sure i think this is all
just really really early but it's gonna
it's really gonna change the way we do a lot
of things as well like even meetings i think
a simple meeting could be in the meta verbs
have you seen the program black mirror yes
i have i've watched the entire thing it's scary
it's too okay great okay great so for those that
don't know i think it's a british thing i think
right it's british i i think so i think it's like
a uk show but it's on like netflix yeah so for
those who don't know basically black mirror is
excellent you have to watch it it's basically
like this dystopian future but it's set tomorrow
so it's so relatable and they have all these
different scenarios of how technology basically
you know tomorrow's technology not in
like 50 years but tomorrow's technology
creates this really dystopian reality and so every
time i hear about the metaverse it makes me think
about black mirror because in reality it's really
just going to be people sitting on their couches
putting something on their heads and just
clocking out right plucking out society
and i don't know how i feel about it it kind
like i like it and i like i like what you said
in terms of paris hilton and um i also think okay
here's another thing i also think that um a lot of
people's childhood dreams are going to come true
through the metaverse so like i've always wanted
to try i've always wanted to teleport okay and fly
teleport and fly i don't know what it is as a kid
yeah youtube cool so like i feel that i'll be
able to i feel like the meta bus is gonna be
like one big acid trip where like you just
just fly and transport and i don't know i
could be talking rubbish but that's my only
excitement everything else i'm concerned about
no i totally feel that like i was in vr like
i have a headset um you know like i'll wear it
for too long because then i get dizzy but like
i was in there for a little while and i was like
in this game and i was like on a jet pack and i
literally felt like i was flying like it was it
was pretty insane like it's just like like you see
something and like you feel it in your gut like
type of thing it was it was crazy it was it was
crazy what did you have what headset did you have
um the quest two oculus questions oh oculus
yeah yeah i i don't know it was a gift so i
just like i started using it and it's it's crazy
it really really makes you feel like you're there
yeah i know i actually put the i used the oculus
headset for the first time recently because my
friend works like in the metaverse he's like part
of all of that and so he gave it to me to try and
um it was so cool like the way your hands the
way like you have hands and like you're gonna
click buttons and oh my god yeah how exciting i
attend vr meetups all the time um like my friend
jerome and i uh blockchain universe he always
hosts events and there's always like meetups for
like different people but you put the oculus you
put the oculus headset on and you meet yeah it's
called alt space vr is the app and basically like
there's meetups all the time and like you could
just go in there hang out with people like you
create your avatar and whatever um you have your
hands you and like i've been to like talk shows
where they have like you know the people at the
like it's like as if you're looking at the tv but
like they're actually with you like there's the
panel with the people they're all talking and then
there's the audience i could give reactions like
hearts and whatever and like you could sit in the
chair next to your friend and like be like yo like
this is crazy oh my god it's gonna be so strange i
i feel like i need to get a headset i'm gonna get
a headset but i'm also just like i'm being such
a boomer about it like i'm so old-fashioned like
i'm crazy crazy old-fashioned so like oh my god
i've been being such a boomer about it um but how
long how long until you think this is all gonna
happen you know like meetings in the metaverse and
how long like what are your thoughts do you have
a timeline on this i think it's already happening
which is like the scariest part like it's already
happening there's already meetups all the time
in virtual reality this is something that has
been going on for a long time now so i think
it's not it's not too far away i think like you
know we've already been on zoom a lot of people
are working from home now so you know to like go
the extra step i feel like zoom is one step and
then the next step is like vr like even if you
don't have a headset like alt space the app i
use you could go on your laptop and like you know
walk around you just won't have hands oh i see oh
wait so explain so you can actually do that just
on your laptop oh space yeah like yeah you could
just like walk around like it just it's obviously
just like not 3d and you don't have your hands but
like you could walk around and like still react
with like hearts emojis you could speak to people
um yeah it's pretty cool okay this might be
like an age gap between us but did you ever
use club penguin when you were when you were
younger probably not did you mean it i wanted
to use club penguin but like i literally never
got around to it i know my cousins like they're
like four years older than me they were so
deep in the club penguin oh my god this is
what it reminds me of like this whole thing i
don't know if any of you guys watching ever and
played club penguin but like this is literally
what it reminds me of like i never played um on
the playstation or like xbox or any of that that
was like for me it's like a very like masculine
thing like my brothers did that um but i spent so
much time at club penguin then like i had a pet
and i bought stuff for my pet and yeah
i had like a little igloo house and like
oh my god and i used to like earn money and
things like that and so i don't know i i do really
believe that it's gonna that it's gonna be um a
legitimate thing but um it does it does concern
me how far it goes because i think humans have a
really um terrible tendency to take things too far
um you know we've seen that now anyway um with
everything that's going on in the world right
now um so i don't know i mean another option
as well is the idea that it's going to be
um not just entirely in the meta bus but it's
going to be a kind of seamless integration
between the real world and the metaverse so it'll
be like augmented reality as well and so we won't
so we won't necessarily completely tap out of this
world it would be sort of together side by side
you do you know what i mean oh yeah 100 there are
apps out now that you could actually like attach
your like metamask over to and buy a plot of land
that could represent like times square for example
and put your nfts or just an image there so if
anyone else has that app they could walk over
to your plot and put their camera up and see
your nfts and see that you own that platform
like that that's something that's already here
yeah gosh it's so crazy i wonder how do you
know what i'm actually afraid of in some ways
i'm afraid of of becoming of getting older and
becoming that person that like doesn't understand
the new technology because like what you just said
no no like what you just said goes right over my
head so like when you come back to miami you'll
have to show me um i'm afraid of becoming that
person that just no no it's hard it's hard to
keep up it's hard to you know it's really hard to
keep up with like all the different things that's
happening different apps different technology
um yeah i think it's difficult to stay on top of
all of it i mean i don't know for me it's like
not like difficult just because like i'm just
scrolling through twitter all the time i'm like so
immersed in this stuff that i don't even realize
it it's like when i talk i'm like oh i knew that
like it's so weird it's crazy but like yeah i i
think it's funny how you're talking about like
how you're being such a boomer about it but like
you're like leading people into digital money and
people i know still don't even have debit cards
there's still people that are literally writing
checks to pay things oh still that's what i was
going to ask you so have you ever opened up a bank
account then or just no no i have yeah but you did
like i don't really do anymore but like um i was
getting paid in fiat for a little bit and i've had
to you know use a bank account for that um and
when i was little like i had a savings account
like that was before my family and i really
found out about cryptocurrency and its wonders
um and i used to have savings now i have bitcoin
so it's like i thought you know i saw like my
money was only staying that amount like that
like a 200 that 200 or whatever was staying 200
and i couldn't do as much with that 200 dollars
so then i was like oh big that makes sense and
how did your dad get into crypto i've never asked
you that he was actually you know like scrolling
on facebook one day and found bitcoin ben's live
stream i don't know if you know who bitcoin ben is
um he was he used to be a truck driver so my dad
caught him like early on when he was in his truck
every morning and he was talking about like this
bitcoin and this litecoin so my dad thought it
was an actual physical coin and started googling
it and then he was like oh okay so this is like
digital money and he started getting into it made
friends and then he was talking to me about it and
i was like yeah whatever um fast forward five six
years here i am so i think it's amazing i think
it's so exciting and then obviously there's the
whole news with facebook and you know with their
metaverse which is obviously going to be quite
centralized um versus i think like the winklevoss
have just um raised the i think i don't know i
could again pulling this number after now i think
it's like 400 million dollars i think don't quote
me um on building a decentralized metaverse um
so would you ever be interested in using like a
meta type metaverse which is more centralized i
mean the oculus is made by facebook so i mean like
that's that's who is like i think the leading vr
people like i don't i haven't heard of another vr
company i mean i haven't looked into it that much
that sells headsets but oculus is definitely
the top right now and that's made by facebook
but i do think that there's gonna be
decentralized versions and you know i
think you know some people are gonna want to use
that the centralized ones and that's like cool but
again it's like all freedom of choice and like
we're like i'm probably gonna dip into each one
and like see what's up but i obviously prefer
like you know if there's like a decentralized
thing i could probably have more utility on
there then yeah that would be really cool
i think you and i obviously were having this
conversation and we obviously agree that all
of this is inevitably the future so do you ever
meet people who are much older and like how do
you start convincing them just as an example um
like i had like um i didn't break my knee but i
basically injured my knee earlier this year um
and so the guy that was like fixing my knee i got
into a whole debate with him about like bitcoin
versus gold and like i was going through it like
i was at the hospital going through it with him
like no there's bitcoins like this and gold is
like that and everything that he said i was like
coming back like fire it was good fun so like have
you ever been in that kind of situation and what
is your sort of go-to argument which really just
um explains why this is the future well it depends
on who i'm talking to really but like if they're
if they're going like you know if they're just
saying like oh i don't understand digital money
i'm gonna be like well do you use your debit card
do you transact over the onset as it is uh and
they're like yeah so i'm like okay you're doing
that already now here's bitcoin and this is why
bitcoin's important and i go into like store value
almost it's peer-to-peer no intermediate like no
third parties um it's borderless any anyone with
an internet connection could transact and they're
like oh okay um you know of course like you know
there are there are people that value like that
just don't want to invest in crypto they don't
believe in it they believe in like you know their
national currency and like that's cool that's
fine i could just say like you know would you
rather have your dollar from like 11 years ago
when bitcoin was like six cents or would you
rather have your the bitcoin from then the
one dollar from then or the one dollar from
now yeah it's a really good point and i think
yeah i think i think like you know inflation
and showing them um you know how the purchasing
power of these fiat currencies are just crashing
um there's a really good way to go about it um i
think you know it's interesting when you when you
you know talk about it as like have your national
currency um i won't make you comment on this don't
worry um you're welcome to if you want to um
but you know like it's interesting because
i think um from my perspective everything
that's going on in the world right now we
tend to see um a lot of nations really just like
screwing over their citizens um and that's all
you know if for example like the medical mandates
come in in the in england i for one will feel
like um my country has just screwed me right like
my country just discriminating against me and
hates me and and so as a result like i don't want
to hold their money like it's even that you know
i don't feel i don't feel patriotic to a certain
currency i don't feel any love for a certain
country i don't feel an edit for that patriotism
of course if you look at the purchasing power of
the pound it's been crashing inflation is up 4.2
from what they've said so there's many different
things which makes me you know obviously not want
to use it but then on top of that just using the
time like national currency it has such like
patriot patriotic kind of tendencies involved
in that and i for one at this point i'm just
like i'm no longer a patriot unfortunately um
given everything that's going on right now in the
world um so what i love about crypto is how it's
it is apolitical you know like it is it is it is
it is a political and i think that bitcoin tends
to um you know be borderless it's not doesn't
belong to a tree there is no politics involved and
i really enjoy that um and i know el salvador are
doing a lot um when it comes to that have you ever
been to el salvador do you have any interest um
in checking out the bitcoin city oh i definitely
want to check it out for sure i did there's like i
saw like a lot of pretty parts like a lot of like
i saw like pictures of like very nice beaches and
i was like wow like you know like it's definitely
a place i want to visit one day i know there's
a lot of bitcoin adoption so it would just like
be cool to like walk into somewhere like and just
know that like i'm gonna scan the qr code and like
pay with bitcoin like that's just so exciting to
me and like i just like like you know transacting
with crypto it just like feels extra zesty it
feels fun and like it feels it feels right it
feels right in my heart yeah so wet so when are
you going uh hopefully in the future i i have
no clue hopefully you know hopefully we all moon
and i can't i could go yeah i think it's amazing
i think it's amazing i think it's interesting
how much hostility el salvador has had when it
comes to from from the us from the imf um
and did you see that did you see the tweet
um he did so many um the president he was sort of
saying somebody asked like does he trade from his
does he trade for the country from his from his
laptop and he said his phone did you see that
no way he took it but that's really funny yeah
he was like no i trade for my phone and i don't
know i think it's really interesting i think it's
really i think it's really refreshing to have um
like somebody youthful running a country
who really shares the same mindset as a
lot of us you know um even when it comes to
like taxes and things like that bitcoin city
zero attacks zero capital gains zero income
zero inheritance yeah just zero zero zero zero
um that's crazy i heard i heard that i
heard about that you know it's really
interesting and i i love seeing like
pictures of people like accepting it
transacting with it i'm really impressed like
it all happened really fast and you know it
it's happening i think people it's going
pretty smooth i haven't heard anything like
people like didn't want to use it i think
it's so easy who do you think will be next
oh i don't know that's so hard to tell i just
think like it's all gonna like i feel like it's
all gonna be like one big wave i don't know when
i feel it coming i feel like there's definitely
gonna be more announcements like more countries
using it as legal tender but i feel like it's just
all inevitable you know like businesses are gonna
start accepting it and you know it's just gonna
be too hard to stop so you know we might as well
make it legal tender when it gets to that point
it's true i've been talking about this actually
a lot recently about um levels of regulation
and levels of um to what extent really can
bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies be banned
and i think what's interesting is if governments
try to ban it when it first um came out when it
was first launched they'd have a great job of
doing it right like i really think they would um
you you know it wasn't that decentralized at the
time given there weren't that many miners on the
network naturally yeah um and so it'd be easier to
shut down however now i think it's gonna be harder
but i also think we're still outputting i was
tweeting about this earlier that i think that like
the establishment is still so arrogant like i
don't think they realize the extent to which
bitcoin can literally dismantle it all and i i
think that's so arrogant towards it you know so
i don't think they realize and when they realize
i think it will be too late basically that's
what i'm saying like it would have grown
and the network effect would be too strong
yeah i'm not sure about that i think that you know
this is just all inevitable and i think that a lot
of people you know especially the higher ups i
think they definitely know about bitcoin but i
think they're just figuring out like you know
how can we how can we use this since it's here
totally so on a personal level then what are your
final goals you know i know you obviously we spoke
about earlier you don't want to go to university
you're going to just like grow crypto like what
does that mean you know what are your personal
goals my personal goals is to keep educating
people whether that be on you know a tv level
i was just on fox business on thursday um with
charles payne you've been on with him as well oh
my gosh twinsies um but yeah like that was really
that was really cool so whether that be on a tv
level doing workshops uh creating content whatever
it is i'm gonna keep educating people and keep
going on this path on spreading crypto adoption
to gen z educating the masses and you know
helping us all be our own banks in our own store
because this space is just too good and to not
share all this information it's like holding all
this good information to yourself it's not doing
any good might as well share that share it share
the knowledge i totally agree with you totally
agree with you i think it's super exciting so
where can people find you how can they follow you
everyone you can find me on the twitter instagram
tick tock everywhere clubhouse all at miss teen
crypto visit my youtube channel i'm missing crypto
like subscribe leia was actually on my
show a few weeks back so you can find
that episode and rewatch it all these links on
are on missteencrypto.com you can check out my
nfts from there as well and my about if you
want to check out that clip from fox business
that's amazing guys go follow miss teen crypto
she's out there educating people all the time
which is so incredible we totally need it in
this space um i want to thank you so much for
coming on it's always good to speak to you
please come back to miami so we can hang out
and yeah guys i want to thank you so much
for tuning in thank you see you later bye